In order to fully get in to character, and
sometimes to work up some nerve, performers
will occasionally make decisions at work that
the rest of us would get fired for even thinking
about.
Drinking, drugs, having an annoying voice
— in cubicle life, that’s a recipe for
disaster.
But living life on the big screen can be daunting,
and sometimes it’s not as glamorous as it
looks.
If you like what you’re about to see, check
out out YouTube channel for more of our videos.
And stick around, because we saved the best
entry for last.
These are 10 Popular Actors Who Made Shocking
Decisions For Their Movies.
Jennifer Lawrence, Passengers
We can’t blame Jennifer Lawrence for being
apprehensive to do a sex scene with a married
man— even if that man is Chris Pratt and
the sex is 100% fake.
Plus, Pratt’s wife Anna Faris is in the
biz too, so she gets it.
We can’t think of three more down-to-earth
people.
Nevertheless, Lawrence was still a bundle
of nerves at the thought of being a potential
homewrecker that she got a little boozed-up
before shooting the scene.
It worked.
Nobody got divorced.
And the sky hasn’t caved in.
At least, not yet anyway.
Daniel Radcliffe, The Harry Potter Franchise
Let’s go all the way back to 2001.
A time when Daniel Radcliffe was young, innocent,
and hadn’t yet appeared naked in front of
hundreds of London theatergoers.
Maturing in the spotlight ain’t easy.
And while kids used to have the luxury of
growing up and making mistakes in front of
a relatively small number of people, Radcliffe
did not.
The actor started to do what all teenagers
do and discovered the joys of partying.
And when his habit got out of hand, it resulted
in him sometimes coming in to work still tipsy
from the night before.
Radcliffe has since spoken publicly about
his struggle and successful journey to recovery.
Anna Kendrick and Olivia Wilde, Drinking Buddies
Some actors are really good at feigning drunkenness,
and others?
Not so much.
But then there’s a third category of people—
those who don’t see the point in pretending.
While filming Drinking Buddies, Anna Kendrick
and Olivia Wilde lived in that third category.
Every beer on screen is real, and so is the
consumption.
Writer and director Joe Swanberg set the movie
in a brewery, and figured it would be downright
wrong to let that much beer go to waste.
While they weren’t the only cast members
to crush brewskis on set, they arguably had
the most fun.
Brad Pitt and Edward Norton, Fight Club
Filming a movie involves long hours, hard
work, and lots of manpower.
Every production needs the opportunity to
blow off steam.
But one night while everyone was relaxing,
Fight Club director David Fincher kept the
camera rolling.
Fans of the movie will recognize a scene where
Edward Norton and Brad Pitt are hitting a
couple of golf balls into the distance.
But what’s interesting is this part of the
movie was never in the screenplay.
It was filmed by the director as the two actors
were blowing off steam and having some drinks
to end the day.
They were drunk for real, and repeating the
lines Fincher was whispering to them off camera.
Kevin Spacey, American Beauty
American Beauty is a movie about figuring
out who you want to be.
It follows the stories of one family, and
explores how our connections to each other
can dissolve slowly.
Kevin Spacey plays Lester, a man at a crossroads.
And while his performance is powerful, it
didn’t start out that way.
Director Sam Mendes said in an interview that
the key ingredient in getting Spacey to embody
Lester was to get him a little high.
The director says that such a methodical and
calculated approach toward the character just
didn’t work.
And since Spacey is a details man, the only
way to bridge the gap was with a joint.
The joint he and Wes Bentley share is a real
one, and since it slowed Spacey’s brain
down, Mendes argues the movie is better because
of it.
Carrie Fisher and Harrison Ford, Star Wars
The seventies were a time where you could
throw a party and all different kinds of people
would show up.
The stars partied hard.
And when Carrie Fisher was shooting Star Wars,
so did she.
The actress has talked about doing a full
day of shooting only to turn around and party
the night away.
On one fateful evening she found herself at
the same party as The Rolling Stones.
As she told it, Fisher called co-star Harrison
Ford to get his ass to the party, so he did.
The two actors spent the night drinking and
stumbled into work the next day.
They hadn’t gotten any sleep the night before
so they were not in an ideal state.
But somehow, they did it.
Jesse Eisenberg, Batman v. Superman: Dawn
of Justice
Regardless of how you feel about the finished
product, you can’t deny that Batman v. Superman:
Dawn of Justice is a full-blown media sensation.
The movie incited some of the most intense
nerdy bickering the world has ever seen.
And if you look at them closely, some of the
complaints actually have nothing to do with
the movie.
While audiences have been divided about almost
every element, there does seem to be a consensus
when it comes to Jesse Eisenberg’s portrayal
of Lex Luthor.
On the conservative side, fans could say the
performance was… a surprise.
But more vocal opponents have called it “over
the top” and “shrill”.
In a movie like BvS, obviously Luthor isn’t
the one to cheer for.
So in that way, maybe he’s perfect.
Christian Bale, The Machinist
Christian Bale is a devoted guy.
When he signs on to a movie, the filmmakers
know he’s going to be all in.
And for his role in The Machinist, the actor
wanted to drop a couple of LB’s.
As it turns out, modifying his diet to only
include canned tuna and apples resulted in
him losing more than a few inches off his
waistline.
Bale wanted to get himself down to a hundred
pounds, but since that could have killed him,
the producers were having none of it and stopped
him before it got to that point.
The actor’s next role after The Machinist
was in Christopher Nolan’s Batman Begins.
He had to beef up quite a bit.
And even though we know better, we like to
imagine he did it by adhering to a strict
diet of donuts and milkshakes.
Mmmm.
Donuts.
Charlize Theron, Monster
Charlize Theron has had a long Hollywood career
full of interesting roles.
The talented actress also happens to be one
of the most beautiful humans on earth.
So imagine everyone’s surprise when she
gained 30 pounds, bleached her eyebrows, and
fried her hair to play serial killer Aileen
Wuornos in 2003’s Monster.
Thereon is unrecognizable in the movie, and
gave a performance that earned her both the
Golden Globe and Oscar for Best Actress in
a Lead Role in 2004.
Director Patty Jenkins has said that she needed
someone who wasn’t afraid to get gritty
and emotional.
And Theron definitely delivered.
Margot Robbie, The Wolf of Wall Street
Margot Robbie is everywhere these days, but
it wasn’t so long ago that the actress was
a total unknown.
Hoping to be cast in the next Scorsese flick,
her agents told her not to get too excited,
saying she probably wouldn’t get the part.
Very supportive, guys.
Robbie knew that if she was awarded the part
there was a chance she’d have to appear
nude.
But because her agents were so doubtful, she
wasn’t too worried.
But then she got the call that changed everything.
When it came time to disrobe, the actress
pounded a few shots of tequila to ease her
anxiety.
The director offered to change the scene to
something less revealing.
But, ever the trooper, Robbie insisted on
playing it how it was written.
Thanks for watching our video.
What do you think?
Did we miss any of your favorites?
Join the conversation in the comments section,
and check out our channel to see more videos
like this one.